votre visite commence devant le tribunal
de grande instance de versailles
à votre droite l'hôtel du département et
juste derrière celui ci la préfecture
c'est bien clara une collégienne en
classe de 3e qui vous raconte l'histoire
de famille juive versaillaise durant la
seconde guerre mondiale cet audioguide
numérique
elle a réalisé avec toute sa classe du
collège charles péguy aux généraux
concours téléphone dès qu'on arrive à la
zone de la première balise baïnes jeu
géolocalise directement donc le parcours
démarre automatiquement
donc ensuite on clique sur itinéraire on
a toutes les balises on peut choisir
lors du coup dans laquelle on veut
commencer 16 balises pour un parcours
dans la ville ou bien découvrir chez soi
depuis son ordinateur
donc on va avoir une map qui nous
présente toutes les parties on a et
après dessus donc par exemple je clique
sur la 7ème l'histoire avec où ça se
situe on va avoir un lait un tout un
texte sur l'audio avec les images qui
raconte l'histoire
un vrai travail d'historien qu'ils ont
démarré avec leur professeur madame
coquillard au mois de septembre suite à
une proposition du rectorat de
versailles pour partager leur expérience
ils ont installé une exposition au sein
du centre de documentation de leur
établissement donc là c'est au mémorial
de la shoah où on sait aussi rang on a
aussi rendu visite
il y avait tous les noms des juifs qui
ont été déportés par les pour aller dans
des camps d'extermination
il vous faudra environ deux heures pour
découvrir gratuitement l'ensemble de
leur travail
ce projet intitulé par les vivants a été
réalisée dans trois autres
établissements
le collège charles péguy et le seul
franciliens à s'être lancés dans
l'aventuré pour l'instant